let's begin by talking about the notion
of quantum advantage
now as we all know quantum computers
seem to be more powerful than classical
computers
perhaps the most famous example of this
apparent advantage is given by the
factoring problem
where by peter shore's landmark result
a quantum computer can factor an integer
in polynomial time
whereas there's certainly no known
classical polynomial time factoring
output
however while it is the case that for
certain very special problems
like factoring and in certain settings
like time complexity
we do have this apparent super
polynomial quantum advantage
it's certainly not the case that quantum
computers are some sort of
super machines that outperform classical
computers by some
gigantic margin on all problems
instead the more accurate statement is
that quantum computers
seem to be more powerful than classical
computers
sometimes for example
consider the query complexity of a total
function here it's been proven that
quantum has the most polynomial
advantage over classical
and so this is a setting in which strong
limitations on quantum advantage
are known in this paper
we study the quantum advantage question
in the small space setting
and we prove tight limitations on the
degree to which quantum can outperform
classical
particular we give the first example of
a language
that can be recognized by a classical
algorithm in log space and polytime
but for which no quantum algorithm can
do any better
that is any quantum algorithm that
recognizes this language in polytime
needs log space and so this is a setting
in which provably there is no quantum
advantage
our second example pertains to the
finite automata world
here we give the first example of a
language that can't be recognized by any
sort of classical two-way finite
automaton
in any time bound but can be recognized
by a quantum to a finite automaton
in exponential time and for which
exponential time is provably needed
and so this second example gives a
setting in which quantum advantage
exists
but strong limitations on quantum
advantage can now be given
far more generally we give a new
technique
that can be used to lower bound the
quantum time space complexity of
any language and the above mentioned
results are just special cases of this
far more general technique
but before delving into the details of
these results
let me first spend a minute trying to
convince you that space
actually matters in quantum computation
now the existence of this apparent
quantum advantage for certain important
problems
like factoring has provided excellent
motivation for constructing real
physical experimental quantum computers
and after several decades of progress
we've entered what john prescott calls
the noisy intermediate scale era of
quantum computation
where here intermediate scale refers to
the fact these quantum computers have
few qubits for example
consider a state-of-the-art quantum
computer ibm's q system
which has 53 qubits
to put that number in perspective we can
compare this state-of-the-art
model computer with a not at all
state-of-the-art classical computer
apple's iphone 7 which has 128 gigabytes
of memory
and has a retail cost of something like
400
now i don't know exactly how much ibm's
q system costs to build that
especially some sort of trade secret but
i think we can safely assume it's a
great deal more than 400
of course this is a somewhat unfair
comparison because
when once the iphone 7 has 128 gigabytes
of memory that is conflating together
multiple different kinds of memory
but the basic message is true current
and near-term quantum computers have few
qubits
they have a small amount of quantum
memory and so space
really is important in quantum
computation and if you believe that
then it's natural to try to understand
what is the power of a quantum computer
that has only a small amount of space
we first focus on the extreme case of a
quantum computer that has only a
constant amount of space which we model
using finite automata
in particular we consider the two-way
quantum classical finite automaton
or 2q cfa as version defined by a minus
and watros
as follows we start with a two dfa
there's a two-way deterministic finite
automaton and we augment it with a
quantum register of constant size
we allow the machine to interact with
the squam register however it likes
performing arbitrary unitary
transformations and arbitrary quantum
measurements
and we allow the machine to use the
results those quantum measurements
however likes
now as this is a standard model i won't
spend any more time belaboring the
details of the definition
but they are here on the slide and so if
you'd like to spend a moment staring the
details
feel free to pause the video at this
point continuing
in the same paper in which ambinus and
watros first defined this model
they also exhibited two examples of
languages for which
2qcfa provably outperform any sort of
classical finite dominant
the first such example was the language
leq which consists of a run of zeros
following equal at the front of once
as they showed a 2q cfa can recognize
its language in order n to the fourth
time
and in a recent paper i improved that to
n cubed time
of course one can't hope to do much
better as trivially this language can be
recognized in little o n
time now as a 2q cfa is just a
2dfa plus a quantum register it's
natural to compare
2qcfa with 2dfa where it's known
that 2dfa cannot recognize its language
in any timebound
however to be completely fair we should
also compare 2qcfa
with to a probabilistic binautometer
which are simply 2dfa that have been
augmented with the ability to flip coins
as probabilistic computation is a
particular case of classical computation
2pfa actually can recognize this
language in exponential time
but there's a matching lower bound
exponential time is provably neat
and so this language really is an
example of provable quantum advantage in
the constant space set
a 2q cfa can recognize it in polynomial
time where the two pfa
needs exponential time the second
example considered by unbiased and
watchful
was the palindrome language which they
showed can be recognized by a 2qfa
in exponential time this then gives us
another example of
provable quantum advantage in the
constant space setting as it's known
that 2dfa
and even 2pfa cannot recognize
palindrome in
any time bound but what about a lower
bound for 2q cfa
can we do any better is there a 2qfa
that recognizes palindrome in
sub-exponential time maybe even in
polynomial time that's what's the case
for
leq more generally is there
any language that can be recognized by
two qfa and exponential time which we
can prove
can't be recognized in sub-exponential
time or at least
not in polynomial time these were
all open questions which we resolve in
this paper
in particular we prove no you can't do
any better than the original abundance
watchers construction
no 2qfa can recognize palindrome in
sub-exponential time
where we emphasize that this is the
first example of a language that
provably requires exponential time on a
quantum finance
now this result for palindrome is merely
a special case of a
far more general result namely for any
language
l we prove a lower bound on the running
time of any 2qfa that recognizes that
to be precise we show the running time
has to go at least as fast as the
non-regularity of l raised to the power
of some constant b
where non-regularity is a particular
hardness measure of a language region
defined by dwarf and stockmeyer
and this constant b just depends the
number of states of the two queue cfa
if we then consider the particular
example of palindromes
then we can establish an exponential
lower bound on the non-regularity of
this language
which by the above general result then
immediately implies that no 2qsfa can
recognize palindrome in sub-exponential
time
now in order to put our lower ground for
2qcfa in perspective
it's natural to compare to the analysis
result for 2pfa proven by dork and
stockmeyer
who show that the running time of any
2pfa is lower bounded by an exponential
in their art of measure where we note
that
both of these lower bounds are
essentially tight that is the dwark
stockmar lower bound for 2pfa is
exponentially stronger than our lower
bound for 2q cfa
however this exponential difference
can't be helped
this is merely yet another example of a
setting in which quantum computers
exponentially outperform classical
appears
provably now all of the results stated
so far
apply to quantum finite automata which
are just quantum computers that have
only a constant amount of space
we next observe that the same technique
also yields results for quantum
computers that use a
small amount of space in particular
consider a quantum turing machine leaves
a space s n which is sub-logarithmic
that is little o log n space or if you
prefer
you can consider the more standard but
equivalent quantum circuit model
in which case this is just a quantum
circuit on smn cubits
then for any language we prove a lower
bound on the running time of any such
machine that recognizes that language
where now this lower bound is expressed
in terms of both the non-regularity of
the language
and the amount of space we allow the
machine to use
in the interest of brevity we'll just
consider one example the palindro
language
again here we prove that no
sub-logarithmic space quantum computer
can recognize palindrome even if given
time two to the n to the one minus
epsilon
to put that lower bound in perspective
note that even a deterministic computer
can easily recognize palindrome in log
space and polytime
and so a quantum computer can certainly
do the same but our lower bound says the
quantum computer can't do any better
if one wants to recognize palindrome and
polytime then log space is necessary
to provide further context for our lower
bound recall that
any language that can be recognized by a
quantum computer in log space can also
be recognized by a deterministic
computer in log squared space
both this results in our result provide
strong limitations on quantum advantage
in the small space setting
but the exact details of those
limitations are incomparable
next i want to discuss the key tool that
was used to prove
all the results mentioned so far which
is a quantum analog
of the classical crossing sequence
argument
now crossing sequences are an ancient
technique
defined originally by henny in 1965
who used them to prove lower bounds
against deterministic turing machines
for example what can show that any
language that can be recognized in time
little o and log n
must be right penny's original
deterministic crossing sequence
technique was then generalized to
probabilistic computation
by dwergan stockmeyer and greenberg and
weiss which enabled them to prove their
lower bounds against two pfa that were
stated earlier
i can now generalize this technique even
further to quantum computation
and then using these quantum crossing
sequences i can prove the various lower
bounds against 2qcfa
and small space quantum computers that
were stated earlier
the remainder of this talk will be
devoted to explaining this notion of
crossing sequences
first i'll briefly sketch henny's
original deterministic crossing sequence
argument
and then i'll provide a high level
overview of my quantum analog
suppose we have a deterministic turing
machine m
and suppose we also have an input string
that's been partitioned into two pieces
the left part of the string will call x
and the right part we call y
we then run m on the input x y and we
consider the path
m's head takes during this computation
so in this example the head first
meanders around the x part of the string
for a while changing direction multiple
times
before the first time it crosses into
the y part of the string and it moves
around the y part of the string for a
while
crossing back to the x part of the
string it moves around the x part of the
string for a while crossing back into
the y part of the string
and so on we then
keep track of the state the finite
control of m is in
each time m's head crosses the boundary
between x and y
so the first time we cross from x into y
the finding control is in state c1
then we cross from y back into x and
state c2 and so on
we then define the crossing sequence of
m on the partitioned input x y
as the sequence of states c1 c2 and so
on that m is in
and its various crossings in the
boundary
so that's the definition of a crossing
sequence
next we will see how crossing sequences
can be used to prove lower bounds
let's now consider running m on a pair
of partition inputs
x y and x y prime where it's only the
suffixes of these two strings that
differ
suppose that the crossing sequence of m
when it's run on the input x
y is identical to the crossing sequence
of m on x y prime
then we claim that m has to make the
same decision on x y and x y prime
that is both of these inputs can be
accepted or both have to be rejected
let's see why that's the case we
consider running m
on x y and on x y prime
the goal will be to understand the
relationship between these two
computations
let's start by thinking about the
initial segment of the computation of m
on the input x y where here we pause the
computation
as soon as m's head crosses the boundary
into the suffix y if we then consider
the analogous initial segment of the
computation of
m on x y prime we immediately see that
these two initial segments
must be identical simply because these
two inputs
share the same prefix x
we then consider the second segment the
computation
of m on the input x y
where now we pause this computation
after the next boundary crossing
if we then consider the analogous second
segment of the computation of
m on the input x y prime this part of
the computation might look completely
different
as the suffix y and the suffix y prime
might be very different strings
however by our assumption that the
crossing sequences are identical
we can conclude that m is in the same
state c2
after the second crossing in both cases
continuing this process we then consider
the third segment
the computation in each of these two
cases and we observe that these segments
must be identical this follows from the
fact that at the beginning of the third
segment
the relevant portion of the
configuration of m is exactly the same
in both cases this is say
the finding control of m is in the same
state c2
head is in the same position one cell to
the left of the boundary
and the portion of the tape to the left
of the boundary has the same contents in
both cases
of course this may no longer be the
string x as m could have overwritten
part of that string during the first
segment of this computation
but as those first segments were
identical the string
in the left part of the tape will be
identical in the two cases and so the
third segment the computation will be
identical in the two cases
continuing we then consider the fourth
segment of the computation
of m on x y and the fourth segment of
the computation of m
on x y prime which again might look
completely different
but by our assumption that the crossing
sequences are identical
we know that m is in the same state c4
after the fourth crossing
in both cases we then continue this
process
until m eventually holds on the input x
y
in this example that happens during the
fifth segment
and m accepts by the same arguments
before
the corresponding segment of m's
computation on x y prime must be
identical
and so m must accept x y prime as
desired
the same argument proves the claim in
the general case
identical crossing sequences imply
identical answers
next we consider a lower bound technique
that makes use of this claim
suppose we have a hard language l
and suppose we also have a deterministic
turing machine m
that recognizes l quickly where i won't
be at all specific about the
hardness measure or running time bound
be considered here
what we would like to do is find a bad
pair of partition strings x y and x y
prime
such that m has to make mistake on one
of them
thereby contradicting the assumption
that m recognizes l quickly
to accomplish this we require one of the
strings to be in the language
and the other string to be not in the
language and we also require
m to have identical crossing sequences
on these two strings
if these conditions are satisfied then
by the previous claim
m must make the same decision on these
two strings
but only one of them is in language and
so m
must be wrong on one of these two
strings
next i will give an overview of my
quantum version of crossing sequences
here we consider running a 2qcfa m
on a partitioned input x y
now of course the basic setup here is
quite similar to that of the
deterministic case that we've just
considered
however the fact that we are now working
with a quantum model of computation
adds all sorts of new difficulties
in particular suppose we try to mimic
the definition of deterministic crossing
sequences
by considering the path the head takes
during this computation
then we immediately run to a problem as
quantum measurement is a probabilistic
process
and so whenever a 2q cfa performs a
quantum measurement
the machine probabilistically branches
according to the different possible
measurement outcomes
and so what we've really illustrated
here is the path taking by the head
in a single branch of the computation
moreover even if we ignore this issue at
the moment
and just fix our attention on one single
branch of the computation
we then immediately run to a new problem
suppose we try to keep track of m state
every time this single branch crosses
the boundary between x and y
in the previous deterministic case this
only entailed keeping track of the state
of the finite control of the machine
however now in the current 2q cfa case
we have to deal with a much more
complicated notion of state
as we have to consider both the classic
state of the finding control
and also the current contents of the
quantum register
which is described by a quantum state
and so we immediately have these two
serious issues
the probabilistic computation tree and
this more complicated notion of state
which we will have to deal with in order
to define a quantum analog of crossing
sequences
though other issues will also arise
later in the analysis
we begin by considering the structure of
a 2q cfa's probabilistic computation
tree
as before we run m on the input xy
the total configuration of m at any
particular point in time
and on any particular branch of the
computation is described by a triple
consisting of the current classic state
the current quantum state
and the current head position each node
of the computation tree
consists of a single configuration in
particular the root of the tree
is simply m's configuration at the very
beginning of the computation
in order to populate the rest of the
tree we run m one step at a time
each step of the computation involves
either applying a unitary transformation
to the quantum register
or performing a quantum measurement as
well as also
updating the classic state and moving
the head one cell in either direction
the choice of which operation to perform
at any given step
depends only on the current classic
state and the input symbol that's
currently under the head
suppose for example that the first step
of the computation
involves applying a unitary
transformation
then the initial configuration will have
a single child
given by the configuration that m will
be in after that transformation
suppose the next step of the computation
involves instead
performing quantum measurement then for
each possible outcome of that
measurement
the current configuration will have a
child given by the configuration that m
would be in
assuming that measurement outcome occurs
now of course different measurement
outcomes may occur with different
probabilities
and so each child may be reached with a
different probability
continuing this process one step further
it may be the case that in one
configuration
a quantum measurement is performed
whereas in a different configuration a
unitary transformation is formed
next we'll use these computation trees
to define a
stopping ensemble of a 2q cfa which is a
quantum analog of
torque and stockmeyer's notion of a
stopping ensemble of a 2pfa
as before we consider running m on the
input xy
but now we only run m until it has
finished computing on the prefix x
where we say that a particular branch of
the computation has finished computing
on x
as soon as that branch crosses into the
y part of the input
or accepts or rejects
to illustrate this idea let's consider
an example
of a possible computation of m one step
at a time
we start with the initial configuration
of m the configuration after one step
the collection of possible
configurations after two steps and then
the collection of possible
configurations after three steps where
in this example
the leftmost branch the computation has
accepted and so
has finished computing we then continue
running the remaining branches
and after the next step the rightmost
branch of the computation
has crossed from the x part of the input
into the y part of the input
and so that branch has finished
computing on x
we then pause that branch the
computation
in our analysis we don't modify the
behavior of the machine
and then we continue running the
remaining branches
after a while all the branches in this
example computation
have finished computed on x
the stopping ensemble consists of
the collection of all terminal
configurations from this process
where we also keep track of the
probability with which each of these
configurations is reached
now i am glossing over certain details
here for example
a given branch might run forever without
crossing
but those issues can be dealt with
we will now describe the entire
computation of m on the input x y
by repeatedly applying the idea from the
previous slide
we begin by considering the initial
configuration of m
and we define the first starting
ensemble to consist of just this one
single configuration
we then run m until it has finished
computing on the prefix x
at which point we have our first
stopping ensemble
a stopping ensemble contains accepting
projecting configurations
which correspond to branches of the
computation which are completely
finished
but it also contains crossing
configurations
which correspond to branches that were
paused as soon as they entered y
we now want to allow those branches to
resume
in order to do this we define a second
starting ensemble
which is equal the first stopping
ensemble
we then run m until it's finished
computing on the suffix y
where now everything is defined
symmetrically that is we run each branch
till it accepts rejects or re-enters x
we then obtain our second stopping
ensemble
and then we keep going now
in order to motivate what's coming next
notice that the process that transforms
an arbitrary starting ensemble to its
corresponding stopping
ensemble has a very nice description
namely
all we do is run each branch until it
accepts
rejects or crosses the boundary between
x and y
once therefore
the first stopping ensemble corresponds
to
allowing each branch to cross the
boundary once
the second stopping ensemble corresponds
to allowing each branch cross twice
and so on this naturally suggests using
the sequence of samples to define
a crossing sequence unfortunately
there's a problem
these ensembles are very messy objects
which
simply aren't suited for the kind of
analysis one would like to perform in a
crossing sequence based lower bound
argument
to avoid this problem we replace each of
these ensembles
with the density operator that describes
it where of course many different
ensembles are described the same density
operator
but they are all equivalent for our
purposes
we then define the crossing sequence as
the sequence of density operators
corresponding to the ensembles we saw in
the previous slide
to be precise the first density operator
describes the first starting ensemble
the second density operator describes
the first stopping ensemble which is the
second starting ensemble
and so on next i want to make one
crucial definition related to crossing
sequences which is that of transfer
operator
this corresponds to running m until it
is finished computing on the prefix
x to be a bit more precise
these operators are maps from density
operators to density operators
which convert any starting ensemble into
its corresponding and stop the ensemble
for example the second element of the
crossing sequence is the result of
applying this operator to the first
element
of course one always can divide an
analogous notion for sum x y
now there are just two important
observations i want to make about
transfer operators
the first is that they describe the
behavior of the machine
on just a piece of the input a prefix or
suffix
and the second is that all these
operators are quantum channels
which plays an important role in the
analysis
i conclude by sketching my lower bound
argument
we need a few definitions firstly for
language l
we say that a pair of strings x x prime
is
ln dissimilar if there's a suffix y
such the strings x y and x prime y both
have lend the most n
and exactly one of these strings is in
language
the dwark stock buyer non-regularity of
l is given by this function d sub l
where d sub l of n is the maximum number
of pairwise ln to similar strings
now suppose we have a 2q cfa
m that recognizes l in time t of n
we establish a lower bound on the
running time as follows
we prove that there's a pair of input
prefixes
x and x prime which are ln dissimilar
and the distance between their transfer
operators
is upper bounded by this particular
expression involving the non-regularity
of l
let's consider the consequences of those
two conditions
we run m on the input x y
and x prime y for some suffix y which is
a witness
of l and the similarity by definition
exactly one of these inputs should be
accepted by m
and m of running time t of n on both of
them
we then consider the transfer operators
where as we just discussed
these correspond to running m until it
is finished computing on one of the
prefixes
x or x prime if the distance between
these transfer operators is small
then on any single visit to one of x or
x
prime m will have to behave similarly
but then if the running time is small m
can't possibly make too many visits to
its prefix string
and so now m will have to behave
similarly on x y
and x prime y in particular m
will have to accept these inputs with
similar probability which is impossible
because exactly one of these strings is
in language
therefore the running time must be large
thank you for listening